Bagu Cavia Peking Sushi und noch viel
viel mehr haben wir heute gegessen und
nicht irgendwo sondern in Bern zeners
Lieblingsrestaurant das ist ein ganz
anderes Video als alle anderen aber ich
würde sagen los geht's Freunde wir sind
angekommen und wenn ich sage wir sind
angekommen dann meine ich ich habe noch
überhaupt keinen Plan wo wir hier sind
wir sind schon paar Minuten hier aber
dieses Szenario dieses Restaurant hat
mich wirklich von den Socken gehauen
also vom ersten Moment an als wir
reingekommen sind diese Treppe die man
runterläuft und dann bist du wirklich
ich habe es gerade schon zu dir gesagt
du bist wie in dem Freizeitpark das ist
eine andere Welt hier die du bet ist
halt Erlebnisgastronomie ne muss man so
sagen aber ohne effekttascherei sondern
die liefern halt auch ab das halt das
Ding also dieses gesamt diese
gesamtkposition quasi ne sag ichimmer
das ist wirklich Freizeitpark hast du
sehr gut gesagt aber unterstich ist ja
auch wichtig dass das was du serviert
kriegst nicht nur durch die schönen
Eindrücke getrübt wird sondern das
natürlich auch das das muss auch knallen
also ich habe noch nichts gegessen und
ich habe jetzt schon absolutes
Wohlgefühl und ich bin mir sicher du
würdest mich nicht nur in ein schönes
Restaurant führen sondern wenn Bern
zhner sagt das ist sein
Lieblingsrestaurant dann erlebe ich hier
gleich was was ich vielleicht noch nie
erlebt habe ich möchte dass wenn wir W
wir in zwei Jahren dar drüber noch mal
reden oh weißt du noch im selerk aber
diger also und ich habe wirklich im
Gefühl dass es so ein Abend werden
könnte du hast hier in deiner Hand die
Karte und ich glaube das ist auch kein
Restaurant in den in dem man jeden Tag
sein kann weil es ist auf jeden Fall auf
dem teureren Ende sie faerkalkuliert so
nenne ich das weil wir reden natürlich
von hervorragenden Grundprodukten ne
dafür steht auch Christian Mog mit
seiner Gruppe er nennt es gerne
diethisch arbeitende Speisegastronomie
und das hat natürlich damit zu tun
vieles hat damit zu tun ethisch arbeiten
bedeutet zum einen auf Lieferanten
langfristige Beziehung aufzubauen mit
Topprodukten derine Mitarbeiter fährt zu
entlohnen und das ordentlich zu machen
ja und dem Gästen natürlich auch
Mehrwert zu bieten unterm Strich und ich
glaube das alles spielt natürlich in so
eine Kalkulation auch mit ein also ein
paar Sachen die ich mir jetzt hier
rauspicke wir haben braced beef short
RPS bin ich schon 100% da eine
Pekingente ich habe in meinem Leben noch
keine Peking Ente gegessen wir haben
eine gigantische Auswahl von Sushi
Achtung nach Möglichkeit mit frischem
Wasabi auf highfischha gerieben Bern ich
habe das alles noch was ist das hier wo
sind wir hier ja also so ein klassischen
frischen Wasabi ne eine Wurzel kennt man
ja wir sind so ein bisschen versaut
dadurch weil wir immer dieses Zeug aus
der Tube kriegen eben ich habe noch nie
richtigen frischen Wasabi gegessen ganz
andere Hausnummer es ist das ist
betörend einfach ne also wirst du gleich
sehen ich bestelle uns auf jeden Fall
ein paar Kleinigkeiten zur Vorspeise so
machen wir es nämlich du zeigst mir
warum du dieses Restaurant liebst und
wir essen so wie Du hier essen würdest
hier genau richtig ich würd es niemals
anders machen weil das auf jeden Fall
auch so ein sharing Ding ist ne das ist
ganz wichtig und auch keine Sorge es
wird immer bisschen mehr bestellt als
wir Zwei essen können aber wir haben ein
riesen Team mit uns so das hier wird NS
wegmenoll hung nach Hause geh also Leute
ich sage euch ganz ehrlich ich freue
mich so krass auf das was hier heute
abend passieren wird weil die
Erwartungen sind ganz oben und ich weiß
schon fast dass sie trotzdem übertroffen
werden warten wir mal bis die erste
Speise hier auf dem Tisch steht vor
allem ob es mir gelingt Frankfurt im
besten Licht zu präsentieren ich keinen
Zweifel ich bra
natlich Biss cool a junge also Bernt mhm
du hast gerade wirklich fast jedes
asiatische Wort D ich kenne einmal
gesagt als du bestellt hast also real
Talk s mal ganz ehrlich wie oft gönnst
du dir das weil wenn wir da jetzt ein
price tag dran hängen würden das ist
verdammt teuer und das muss ich aber
sagen würde ich ja nicht reangehen an
die Sachen es ist viel Geld ist viel
Geld ich sag dir wann ich mehr gönne so
einmal im Quartal bin ich hier ja das
jetzt nicht so dass die klar das ist man
kann es schon Stammlokal auch nennen
dann auch ne aber ohne dieses ganze
abgehobene drumhum sondern weil ich
einfach weiß was ich hier bekomme immer
eine sichere Bank immer geil es gibt
nichts Vergleichbares meiner Meinung
nach in Frankfurt und was mir wichtig
ist was ich auch wirklich auch
hervorheben möchte ich höre einfach auf
schlechtes Essen zwischendrin zu essen
und gönn mir dann lieber das das ist mir
wichtiger ne du siehst mich jetzt
niemals in der großen italienerkette od
Pizza essen oder sowas das mache ich
nicht oder wenn eine pastakoch ich mir
zu Hause mittlerweile ich gehe nicht
mehr so da verzichten wir drauf dafür
gönnen wir uns dann das weil ich sag
essen gehen darf was besonderes sein und
dann in diesem Ambiente mit dem was Du
hier serviert bekommst warum nicht das
Match diese Speisekarte ich glaube es
gab nichts darauf was ich nicht geil
finde ab vom Standard und ihr werdet es
gleich sehen wirklich ich freue mich
sehr auf das was kommt geil Alter
schwedeck was geht denn jetzt hier
torspeise ist das ein Bonsai Baum das
ist ein Bonsai
[Gelächter]
natürlich noch ein
kleineschen wie hübsch auch gern
natürlich ja gut ne merkst du wie so
kühl hier drüber zieht aus so das
Trockeneis crazy crazy guck mal boah ja
mama mia also wir haben fast alles
bestellt aber da geht noch ein bisschen
was nur so jedes zweite ein AH geh noch
weiter ganz vergessen Weg hier ja das
stimmt so also fangen mal von rechts an
ne wir haben hier vorne einmal die sexy
Freak Wave dann haben wir die Ginger
beef Ginger beef Roll dann haben wir
hier einmal unsere Trinity laxs einmal
mit wasabio einmal klassisch und einmal
mit JUSO Aburi und Imperial Cavia so
jetzt
MS vielen vielen vielen herzlich Dank
danke schönfür danön absolute ham ich
bin leicht überfordert
aber wie könnte man schöner überfordert
sein als so das ist so eine bernzher
geht Essen Bestellung voll abgehoben
junge nein ich das müsst ihr bitte
verstehen der Bernt geht natürlich nicht
nur so essen sondern Bern wie ich auch
nur wahrscheinlich noch viel mehr
begeistert sich für jegliche Form von
Essen so von der Currywurst bis hin zu
so einer vollkommen Eskalation und das
ist eine vollkommene Eskalation aber
guck mal ich hätte dich ja auch heute zu
ein guten currywur bringen können auch
gefeiert aber aber so vergessen wir
diesen Abend niemals und hier bringe ich
meine Gäste hin und das ist das Wichtige
dabei einfach bevor es los geht noch
eine Sache wenn man mit Bernt in der
Gastronomie unterwegs ist der kennt
erstens jeden und zweitens wird so ein
roter Teppich ausgerollt der Mann der da
gerade hinter uns stand ist der culinary
Director von der restaurantgruppe in der
wir uns hier befinden also wirklich wir
sitzen hier in dem Separ da drüben ist
der ganz normale Gastraum des haben wir
auch voll unsere Ruhe können h mit Licht
unsere Späßchen machen es ist wirklich
einfach also mit dir essen gehen macht
Spaß vielen herzlichen Dank auch an den
Frank MB den kin Director der M Gruppe
dass S uns das ja auch möglich gemacht
haben ganz klar wo fangen wir an ich
würde sagen bei warm oder ja
grundsätzlich ja wobei natürlich müssen
wir warm anfangen es ist natürlich so
ein bisschen unlogisch ne wir wollen die
Zuschauer ja mitnehmen in dem Fall hier
norchmal wird man zashimi starten ist ja
klar aber jetzt wir wollen den Tisch ja
voll haben ne wir wollen was zeigen aber
ich komme an diesen W crackerern einfach
nicht vorbei ne mit dem wakutat und
Cavia oben drauf dieses tiefe Rot das
das WAG tat ja Cavia es ist unglaublich
absolute Wahnsinn da wirst auch das
knallt D Weg sag ich dir gleich ich
wünsche dir jetzt schon viel Spaß bei
diesem Abend du hast viel gesehen Du
hast viel gegessen aber ich glaube das
Gesamterlebnis heute abend ich hoffe
dass dir das gefällt und dass ich das
richtige Restaurant für dich rausgesucht
habe ich habe keine Zweifel lass das un
schmecken hau rein was ich an diesem
Gericht so sehr mag ist das ausgewogene
Verhältnis wirklich viel Tat die Nocke
Cavia oben drauf die man eigentlich
denkt die könnte so dekadent Fehler am
Platz sein ist sie aber gar nicht weil
sie der ganzen Sache einfach hilft ne
dieses cremige Zusammenkommen von der
saourcam das ist eine Götterspeise
wirklich ja für mich ist es der Knaller
ich könnte weinen jetzt nach diesem
eren ohne Witz man denkt so ein Tatar
ist so zurückhaltenend ne du hast sowas
ja einfach so was was so ein bisschen
mild auch schmeckt noch nie SAS leckeres
gegessen ich muss mein drittes
Essen das Geistes krank ja ich will auch
aber okay ich mach's auch muss noch
hinterher dieser ganz dünne war der aber
so knusprig ist also wow aber weißt du
was mich hier richtig anlacht ja ich
weiß es diese diese Dynamite trims die
kann man eigentlich nicht da liegen
lassen kann man nicht kann man nicht du
als erstes natürlich sieht der nicht
auch wunderschön aus dieser Kamerad das
ist auch wirklich eine Granate das ist
ja gigantisch aber guckt dir dieses Ding
an der ist halt in Tempura weiß du dann
haben die außen drauf ich glaub es ist
Süßkartoffel wenn ich mich nicht irre
ich ich merke gerade vielleicht wird es
so eine komplette Eskalation vielleicht
wird das so mit das längste Video was
ich hier hochgeladen habe ist gut
möglich weil ich finde die Gerichte sind
auch wert drauf einzugehen ne also
lieber Max W ich danke dir haust den
echtof einmal weg oder n okay wir weißen
ab boah sehr saftig liegt natürlich
kommt durch die über die Soße ja über
die feurige aber trotzdem cremige Soße
quasi eine Art siraca Mayo ne aber in
ihrer besten Form dann den Tempurateig
außenrum mit dem Knusper oben drauf und
dann hast Du durch den Knusper im Mund
und dann beißt du in die knackige
Garnele und ich liebe das wie wenn du
ein saftigen Apfel beißt weiß der kracht
beim Abbeißen ne und dann hast du in
drin natürlich den perfekten gabpunkt
gefunden das in der Friteuse das ist
halt auch das musst du üben das ist
einfach Hochleistungssport auch ne ich
bin echt schwer beeindruckt was ist das
weil ich will das Essen das sind schumai
quasi auch mit wacu wenn ich richtig
gesehen hab jeden Fall rinfleisch drin
ist eins meiner lieblingsdumling quasi
schon mal weil es ist eigentlich immer
Hackfleisch mit einem mit einem one ton
wrap außen rum gedämpft ja so und die
sind natürlich in ihrer allerschönsten
Form seh wunderschön aus ne auf ein
Bananenblatt oder was ist da unten genau
da ist ein banenblatt unten drunter in
dem Dämpfkörbchen das S nicht an
Dämpfkörbchen festkleben ist das die
Soße dafür genau das wird die Soße dazu
sein W mal probieren oder probieren wir
mal also auch hier ne es sieht wieder
das finde ich auch krass so eine große
Karte zu haben aber man sieht es ja
nichts davon ist hat Abstriche ne es ist
einfach geil nein nein die liefern die
liefern ja lass schmecken
ich meine wer mag denn nicht Fleisch und
Teig gefüllt dann auch noch so diese
kleinen Täschchen von Brühe oder genau
diese juice der drinoll voll voll voll
guck mal hier diese ja mit dem
trüffelschaum drauf das S so spicy
Lobster dampling genau richtig muss mal
gucken ob ein raus weil die sind so dass
sie ja merkst du das das ist so die
haben echt noch noch ein Biss tolle
tolle eine tolle Haptik auf jeden Fall
ja mit dem Schaum dabei
m
ist so schön du schmeckst wirklich die
Butter ne Bo und dieser trüffelschaum
ist so dezent ne du hast steht auch so
so ja der der ist trotzdem total dezent
du hast nicht so eine trüffelkeule weil
Trüffel ist ja so gerade mit so einem
Trüffelöl ne wenn was synthetisches
dabei dann übertünscht das ja so sowas
delikates wie so ein hummeraroma total
aber du hast aber voll seafood ne also
du hast voll dieses
krustentieraroma für dicke Dinger das
junge junge junge junge junge Alter wir
hauen auch gut rein sag sch wie es ist
ne jetzt hast du die Wahl zwischen ein
baubann mit einem knusprigen
Schweinebauch drin oder jakitoris Spieß
yitoris Spieß okay nehmen uns man kennt
ja aus verschiedenen Läden tatsächlich
auch immer diese diese fertigen Spieße
die es gibt gibt ein Produkt das hat
jeder Sushil Laden hat die auf der Karte
weil sie alle denken wir bräuchten das
wir schmecken alle gleich und die
schmecken auch eigentlich gut so das
sind so so nice die Dinger jetzt ist es
ein anderes Ding sag dir wie es ist weil
die sind auf dem robat gegrillt und das
sieht man hier an den Holzstäbchen ne
also die wurden zwangsläufig mitgegrillt
aber das ist ein sehr gutes ze
ach vor allem mit der klebrigen schönen
Soße dazu ne und hier guck mal der Spieß
das ist mitgedacht das sind diese
Kleinigkeiten der Spieß ist sauber du
kannst den anfassen kennst du das von
den anderen Ding die sind dann so immer
klebrig kannst du eigentlich nicht und
rie man da dran das ist echt man hat
yitori Wipes ne dieses Grillaroma
Grillaroma süß der hat das hier eben
reingetragen da habe ich das gerochen ja
es riecht wirklich nach dem robata Grill
ne ein robata Grill ist ein japanischer
Grill mit sehr sehr heißen Kohlen unden
drin kanönn ich jetzt ewig drüber
referieren also brutal das wird dir
richtig Spaß machen bin ich mir relativ
sicher die spiee
kreuzen der K four ist ja stand uns
probieren
wir boah die Grillaromen ich woll gerade
sagen ich habe nur Mund zu voll das
schmeckt so rauchig D man denken Kön W
irgendwie so Liquid smoke oder irgendwas
im Einsatz aber das kommt vom Grill das
short was zum Hauptgang kommt ist auch
von diesem Grill auf jeden Fall auch ein
dickes Ding kann ich aufhören ber ich
liebeitor spie die sind wirklich ja eins
meiner favorites ihr werd euch
wahrscheinlich gedacht haben aber ich
habe noch nie gute yitoris Spieße
gegessen Alter Bern was machst du hier
du zeigst mir ein Restaurant und
komplett Benchmark neug gesetzt auf den
Punkt getroffenes mal baubahn baubahn
baubahn ist ein baubahn mit meinem
Traummann oh der musste kommen relativ
simpel gehalten ne wir haben baubahn
also Hefebrötchen außen Frühlingslauch
häusensoße eine Gurke schön crispy
porkbelly und das war's rein muss diese
Gurke da sein ja wie dick muss diese
Gurke geschnitten sein so weißt du das
das meine ich damit wenn die sich trauen
so ein Ding auf die Karte zu schreiben
was jeder irgendwie schon mal 1us mal
gegessen hat dann wollen sie dass es
performt ne und das halt so ein fin man
hat so durch diese häusensoße und den
porkbelly fast so salzaramellnoten
während man das ist dann kommt so ein
frischer Koriander rein und so das ist
wirklich alter Schwede das ist stimmt du
hast so ein so ein salzig süßes Erlebnis
dabei ne dazu hast du diesen super
knusprigen porkbelly mir macht das Spaß
zu essen wieder es macht mir es macht
wirklich einfach nur Spaß ich bin froh
dass du da bist weil ich bin froh dass
du da bist ich würde das Essen glaube
ich stellen weil wirklich sprachlos
machen und du bist viel sicherer in der
asiatischen Küche unterwegs als ich bin
und ich freue mich also es fühlt sich
auch an als würde ich so von dem Meister
lernen gerade es ist aber auch eine
Sache es muss ja auch schmecken ne wenn
dich Essen überfordert oder sowas und
das ist ja oft so sage ich mal auch im
im im im gehobenen Gastrobereich in der
Sterneküche wenn es sehr
beratungsintensive Produkte sind auch
dann finde ich immer da wird am Tisch
schon so direkt so die Erwartungshaltung
auch geschürt und manchmal denkst du dir
weiß du rein so h ja es war jetzt nett
aber war das so war das jetzt wirklich 5
Minuten erklären bevor du es isst so ein
Ding ist das und hier ist ein einfach
hier s unsere baubahn weiß du so dann
ist du das denkst geil weiß so ganz
banal einfach ja das ist selbstdrehend
ich habe natürlich noch eine Bitte an
dich und zwar könntest Du kurz mal
diesen crispy du hierüber von dem
schwärmst du ja schon seit Anfang an ja
also das ist ja das ist so ein Ding du
weißt ja wie ich immer ticke ich ich
fahre extra her dafür ja mir ein
bisschen Granatapfel sehe ich dann ist
das krresse glaube ich ne da drunter
erscheint schon so ein bisschen Zwiebel
ja knusprige entenhaut ist das ist das
entenhaut ist knusprige entenhaut das
Ding al Schwede ich will hier was
erzählen ich sag ich nur weil ich kenne
sieht natürlich so aus ne aber es ist
knusprige entenhaut das ist das Ding ne
musst du getrennt voneinander zubereiten
wir können ja mal hier so ein bisschen
oh ja geh mal rein noch mal auf das Ding
also da ist natürlich viel Salat oben
drauf und dann unten drunter hier unten
hast du aber knusprige Entenstücke
siehst du das mit der knusprigen Haut
oben drauf genug gequatscht her damit ja
ohne Witz e perfect Bit auf Stäbchen
junge junge Junge ich liebe
mit diesem Sesamöl ne boah das ist geil
das ist geil sutschige scharfe Salat
oben drauf ja mit der geilen Kresse oder
kannst du nicht aufhören das ist einfach
so ein D ich weiß auch ich habe gerade
richtig Angst vor also kenne die
Konsequenzen meines Handelns du willst
aufessen aber ich ignoriere sie du
willst aufessen ich werde gleich satt
sein aber ich muss meine eigenen Grenzen
erkennen und überwinden dann kommt meine
große Stunde gleich wir müssen auch dem
capaco gucken auf jeden Fall ach das
haben wir auch noch ja ich hö schon so
stimmen bei dir so so vipes alter die ja
ich glaube du musst gleich mal ein
Bäuerchen machen W klar ja schön
eiskalter Teller eben auch noch ne schön
angelaufen trüffelm oben drauf und dann
haben wir hier so ein bisschen vom
Crunch ne ja was ist das aber das ist
hundertprozentig entweder das ist vom
Tempura würde ich sagen ja komm wie
machen wir das hier mit einmal sagen
guck mal so ein Ding so bisschen
einfalten wahrscheinlich das ist aber
auch nicht so so peinlich dünn
geschnitten ne gönen Hal ist ordentlich
also die Anrichte ist eigentlich fast
das dekadenteste daran weil man kann
durch diese Soße fast die Marmorierung
von diesem Bagu gar nicht mehr erkennen
und das ist wahnsinnig marmoriert guck
mal perfect qu gebastelt alles drauf was
reingehört lieber Max reingehauen habe
ich heute schon gesagt dass ich meinen
Job liebe ich glaube nicht haben wir
heute schon gesagt dass es ein Privileg
ist das hier tun zu dürfen nein aber
sollten wir auf jeden Fall je machen es
ist ein absolutes Privileg und ich
glaube wir wissen es beide sehr zu
schätzen deshalb lass wir un
schmecken muss man Fleisch normalerweise
nicht kauen eigentlich nee nee das nicht
ich habe ich das irgendwie falsch in
erinung einfach mit der Zunge an den
Gaumen gedrückt dann ist das Weg Alter h
ich habe gesagt zeig mir dein
Lieblingsrestaurant nicht bring mich neu
auf die welting neu auf die Welt es ist
zu viel es ist zu viel ich habe das
Gefühl gehabt ich hätte würde ich hätte
schon ein paar Sachen gegessen aber ich
ich bin das ist einfach so ich bin so
ein ich gehe heute als neuer Mensch hier
raus guck mal was wir sind noch nicht
mal der Vorspeise durch ich bin echt
gespannt was du zum Sushi sagst lieber
Max wir haben gerade so von dem was wir
heute essen haben wir gerade so 20%. er
ich habe hier so eins übrig jetzt ne
komm bitte sei das sollen die Leute
sehen weil der Eric wird das wird das
Fühlen Eric guck mal ich habe ja nicht
wie Max ne ich habe dir eins übrig
gelassen auf jeden Fall ich
konte sag dass das nicht das beste t ist
was duest ich sag dir ehrlich weißt du
was das ist das ist so meine Richtung in
die Richtung Insolvenz weil ich es jeden
Tag
hab und jetzt komm geh mal hier rein es
ist verrückt ne wird jetzt zum
geburtssaal ja zum
Kreiss komm ich hör jetzt auch nicht auf
du musst jetzt alles musst jetzt alles
einmal
probieren habe schon wieder vergessen
wie das heißt aber ich will es jeden Tag
essen also
ja
carpaco also ja gut dann würde ich sagen
guck mal wir machen uns mal so ein
bisschen Platz was du sagst bei Sushi
und Sashimi jetzt weil das wäre der
nächste step den wir jetzt hier gerade
haben ich sage aber bevor wir an das
Sushi gehen was ja auch aromatisiert ist
und so lass uns lieber mal die rohe
Fischqualität checken mit dem wir
mashimi anfangen eine Sache ist ganz
unscheinbar auf diesem Tisch aber du
hast es ganz groß aufgebauscht was ist
der Unterschied zwischen diesem Wasabi
hier das wir alle kennen und diesem
Wasabi hier außer 6,99 € also klar man
sieht natürlich schon farblichen
Unterschied ne das ist jetzt sag ich mal
ein guter Standard Wasabi den man jetzt
aus dem Sushi Restaurant von neben an
kennt und das hier ist natürlich das es
ist ein Wölkchen ja von frisch
geriebenen auf der Haifischhaut
geriebenen Wasabi in der frischen Wasabi
Wurzel ne ich habe dazu schon Dokus
geschaut ne ich habe schon Dokus zu
frischen wasab geschaut ich hab es noch
nie gegessen und hast du mal gesehen wie
der geerntet wird was für ein
das ist ja also eher findest du ab
Ballone also du kannst es auch das
wächst auch nur in Japan das Zeug das
haben alle probiert hier berichtigt mich
gerne in den Kommentaren aber ich sag
dir das ist muss Japan Import sein soll
ich mal pur
probieren bei allem was hier sehe das
hier interessiert mich gerade am meisten
frischer Wasabi also der andere ist ja
oftmals einfach auch sehr sehr scharf
und so ne und der hier hat halt einfach
diese dieses sofort Präsente Wasabi
Schärfe dieses mehrrettigchartige und
dann klingt so fein ab genau ist süßlich
ja zieht dir nie in die nobsmuschel
oftmals ist es so wenn die einen Tag alt
sind war das die müssen frisch sein
ansonsten keine Chance und sie dürfen
nach nichts riechen ja sie riechen nach
Zitrone rie der an der sie jetzt gelegen
haben ja das halt einfach mal so rein
damit es hat sofort was von also es ist
sofort meeresfrühstück und siehst du wie
subtil das einfach im Geschmack ist das
ist einfach so eine so der perfekte
jetzt kommt roher Fisch so ein Ding al
so das ist so und der hat nichts von so
einer gammeligen Muschel die du hier
irgendwie geflemt auf deinem auf deinem
scheißsi serviert bekommst muss man
einfach sagen wie es das und es kann
auch gar nicht vom Vortag sein weil ich
bin gerade mal draußen dur ich den Gas
gaufen ist ist brechen voll was für ein
Tag haben wir heute heute ist die stag
ja Dienstag krass aber der Laden ist
glücklicherweise er freut sich an der
großen Beliebtheit und er ist immer gut
gebucht nicht nur bei dir e jetzt diese
Garnele Gele guck mal auch wie hier
wieder die Präsentation ist die Jakobs
mususchel ist zwischen Scheiben von
Limette dann hast du die Garnelen die
fachgerecht aufgetrennt wureneben hast
du die Garnelenspieß gespieße die
garnelenswänzchen und die auch roh
maximal kurz blongiert ne also auf jeden
Fall inen drin komplett glasig aber ich
denke mal die haben genauso viel
Temperatur bekommen dass sie gerade so
die Textur verändern das nicht wie bei
aus die Du kurz Wärme gibst weißt du
dann wird die auch besser meiner Meinung
nach ja und ich denke das H auch
passiert tolle Qualität Geld ich durfte
mal frisch angelieferten Kaisergranat
probieren als ich einen Tag in die
Sterneküche geschnuppert habe und
Praktikum gemacht habe Alter das da bin
ich gerade wieder boah das ist richtig
bleibt do da und wir haben jetzt nichts
dazu gemacht weder Wasabi noch ein
bisschen ing noch mal ein bisschen
irgendwie Sojasoße gar nichts ist
passiert ne aber beim Sashimi da bin ich
jetzt echt gespannt da bin ich auch
gespannt stell ich uns mal vor die Nase
fast ein Bootsunfall gehabt hier es ist
schön ist ein ganz normaler Label rou ne
ganz normaler so wie jeder im
Kühlschrank hat absolut wegwerfen muss
manchmal weil er einfach abgelaufen
ist jeder also hier ich fange immer mit
tumfisch an probieren wir auf Eis ne was
ich auch mal mag ein echtes schisoblatt
halt nicht dieses Plastik du weißt schon
was ich meine tumfashimi geil geil geil
geil geil das jetzt mit ein bisschen oh
ja da das muss ich auch noch mal ich
wollte gerade schon zum Lachs wechseln
weil ich bin immer ein bisschen mehr Fan
von Lachs außer es heißt Toro ganz
andere
ja so eine schöne Temperatur von unten
so leicht Eis gekühlt ich bin echt
irritiert von diesem Wasabi weil zieht
dir nicht hoch in die Nase ganz verrückt
ganz Vert und guck mal wie also das
sieht aus wie gemalt ne ganz normaler
Lebel Rus jetzt komm guck mal schauen
wir uns das hier mal an auch hier schon
wieder sehr sehr kunstvoll das ganze ne
wie hier so die was ist das ist das noch
Haut ja ne ja auf jeden Fall ne auf
jeden Fall Schut so eingeritzt und
wahrscheinlich sogar geflemt so wie ich
das sehe weil sich so leicht
zusammengezogen hat ne in der Quali
schwer zu bekommen h steht noch ein
Schiffchen habe ich
gesehen merkst du was ja ich krieg
langsam Hunger du hast übertrieben und
da kommt ein wenig keine Ahnung was es
ist an das wird wahrscheinlich magrele
sein kingfisch so wie es riecht auch so
in Röschen ne in so kleinen Röschen
einfach mit Spaß drauf gelegt so auf
Tisch auf gepackt jetzt finde ich es
aber auch gerade wo wir jetzt hier so
einsteigen finde ich es doch
beeindruckend wie schnell das alles bei
uns am Tisch war ist so gell weil es ist
ja es ist ja nicht das ist ja kein
Fastfood die sind gut vorbereitet die
sind gut eingestellt in der Küche die
sind drauf vorbereitet an so einem busy
Abend wie heute auch zu performen ne und
das da zeigt sich auch der Unterschied
zwischen Mittelklasse und den den
highperformen muss man einfach so sagen
und glaub mir ich weiß das ich selbst
hab jahrelang an dem Platz gestanden wo
die Jungs jetzt gerade sind in der Küche
stimmt das ist ja noch der Punkt so ne
deshalb finde ich es auch so schön dass
du diese Wertschätzung und diesen Spaß
an der Sache hast obwohl du das alles
gemacht hast oder gerade weil du das
gemacht hast das will ich probieren
diese leicht geflemmten Lachsen guck mal
die sind auch nicht so Schiffe ne das
ist schon relativ delikate Häppchen
exakt ein schönes ausgewogenes
Verhältnis von Fisch zu Fleisch ja so es
kriegt hier so ein bisschen bisschen SoJ
diip Touch muss man muss man neidlos
anerkennen das ist die beste Wahl für so
ein Sushi ne also haben wir hierum beef
beef beef beef be ich war lange Zeit
kein Fan davon Fleisch auf sushiis zu
legen wirklich lange Zeit nicht und das
ist tatsächlich eine Sache wo ich sage
wenn es gemacht wird dann bitte so ja
sehr sehr geil geil mich bockt schon
richtig so dieses dieses crunchy [__]
komm ne dran da ist wirklich nur so ein
Hauch von Reis drin ne so viel ist da
drin an Füllung du gerade brauchst
einfach ne so um das ordentlich
zusammenzuhalten ja das ist schon geil
freue mich auch schon richtig hier guck
mal wir haben hier wagu wir haben
softell crab wir haben trüffelschaum
außen drauf oh ja da muss ich ran boah
also diese softell crab ist aber auch
trüffelschaum das Beef oben drüber das
macht mir so einen Spaß wä mir mal kurz
so ein bisschen philosophisch bitte wenn
das hier dein Lieblingsrestaurant ist
was bedeutet es für dich hier essen zu
gehen das ist für mich an erster Stelle
steht eine gewisse Wertschätzung weil es
gab sicherlich Zeiten in meinem Leben
habe ich davon geträumt dann gab es
Zeiten in meinem Leben wo ich keine Zeit
hatte dafür und jetzt gibt's die Zeit wo
ich mir das erlauben kann hin und wieder
und das bin ich sehr dankbar dafür ne
für mich ist immer was besonderes es ist
es wird zelebriert auch da ziehe ich mal
ein Polohemd anstatt T-Shirt an weiß du
so ein Ding ist das nein du weißt schon
was ich meine ne für mich SP du kannst
ja nicht wissen wo es hingeht du
konntest es ja nicht wissen ja hier sind
wir doch gerade beim nächsten Feuerwerk
angekommen stichwortmäßig und zwar
gibt's hier die Garnele Lachs außenrum
quasi californiamäisch auch hier
interessante Größe ne also es ist fern
ab der Norm also es sind nicht so so
riesen Rei Brecher sondern es ist
einfach es ist besonders auf jeden
[Musik]
Fall hast das mal Mito probiert ich
dekoriere gerade den Tisch ne ich habe
wirklich so viele Flecken schon auf
Tisch tut mir total
leid so
gut ganz toll jetzt kommt mein
persönliches Highlight und zwar haben
wir ja hier oben noch die kleinen Jungs
mit dem Tatar oben drauf s wirk die
kleinen Jungs ne also ich find das schön
dass das so eine ist eigentlich Mar
Größe in manchen V voll voll voll voll
ja du sehen das performt hart
mhm ist ein bisschen Chili mit drauf
deswegen da ist Gurke drin ja ja aber
auch dieses cremig zitrusartige ist
einfach geilo Mayo wie auch immer jeder
noch ein Stückchen Sushi dann gehen wir
das ans Team weiter und dann geben wir
in der Küche Bescheid dass die uns auf
jeden Fall mal unseren Hauptgang
vorbereiten freue mich so auf diese
paking Ente und alles drum und dran
diger das wird so geil
komm
shortp
alteriert ist schon auf dem Weg ich
dachte das gibt's nur ein Film das Musik
ne das Musik ja Alter schwe auf jeden
Fall boah der Saft der da
raau es klingt so juicy einfach es sieht
auch juicy aus Leute ich sag's euch
jetzt schon das absolut der richtige
Zeitpunkt diesen Kanal zu abonnieren
einen Daumen nach oben zu geben und ein
netten Kommentar zu schreiben weil es
ist einfach wer auch dass Frankie sich
die Mühe macht uns hier so geil die Ende
zu Trieren Hammer und macht genau das
gleiche bei Bernt an der Stelle bitte
auch im Titel drauf klicken alter das
ist verrückt was du mir hier zeigst und
was ihr hier macht vor allem ne du du
sagst ja nur komm mal her und schaust
dir an Max check das aus ber was haben
wir hier bitte alles was soll ich dir
sagen wagu katsu sanlo einfach Toastbrot
Fleisch so kann man es nennen tut der
Sache vielleicht ein bisschen Unrecht
wenn man so hört ist ein Steak Sandwich
ja aber der Glanz bei dem W wow Wahnsinn
oder Wasabi Fries garlic sesuan beans ja
ja voll geil also ne das ist natürlich
hier mit dem mit dem knusprigen
Knoblauch oben drauf und so essen erär
was ist das hier bitte
shortpifeife shortp das zft schon vom
Anschauen so misot und natürlich eine
paking Ente es einfach noch ein döchen
Imperial Cavia aufgetaucht kennst du das
nicht so sitzt man sitzt beim Essen und
plötzlich ah da ist eine Dose Dose Caria
da mach NS mit dem Ding anück
wirklich Alter diese Farbe dieser Glanz
juicy von allen Seiten rein hier nicht
den Fehler ohne K nein nein nein krass
dass du jeden Tag so istst und das Brot
ist wirklich nur dafür da dass die
Finger nicht fertig werden weiß du Mama
mir ist
soweit noch mal geboren
jetzt guck mal
wann hört das auf das bleibt da jetzt
also jetzt musst du einfach aufhören ich
kann nicht das war jetzt weiß so das so
dieses dieses W Fett dieses buttrige
Toast dieser kühlende Cavia oben
drauf ich komme darauf nicht klar das
ist so als hättest Du so so so so ein
Kissen vol voll von den besten
cremigsten saftigsten fleischsäften die
es gibt und das kaufst du so nach und
nach Leer bis nichts mehr davon da ist
Eric muss kommen während ihr hier kommt
wir brauchen ihn er muss kommen und wird
kommen falls nicht wist wie man Cavia
normalerweise probiert ne so ist der
richtige Weg das Ding ist du musst es
Loki ganz nehmen ganz in den Mund rein
Alter wie weich ist das bitte ja one
verloren das kann ich nicht zulassen
nein auf keinen
[Musik]
Fall
[Gelächter]
auch alle lieben Papa Bern alle Kinder
lieben PAP gar Gemach nur
bestellt was kostet das jetzt
beispielsweise über 30 war nicht 69
glaub K hi geh mal kurz die Karte
schus WAG Kanne
h warte mal warte mal warte mal ohne CIA
ohne CIA upgradeat with additional 30
GRS of Cavia noch mal 70 € 170 € sind
daselt lach Habibi Habibi
lach lach
Habibi gut dass ich das auch mal jetzt
das darf hier nicht liegen das muss
jetzt gegessen werden ja vergess den K
nicht Max das Ding ist dieser misokot ne
der darf auch nicht so darf nicht kalt
wden müssen wir müssen hier rein guck
mal einfach hier rein fettes Stück Kott
rausgeholt und mal ohne Soße einfach
probiert und hier mal reingeguckt bitte
was wir hier einfach für ein juice drin
haben ist der perfekte
garrad außenrum schön lackiert mit Miso
das ist der absolute Hammer weiß dieser
Kott ist wirklich guck mal das an wie
wie perfekt der gebraten ist Alter Bern
was ist das krass gell
ne ist wirklich krass ich liebe den also
mit welcher Fettigkeit der daherkmt mit
welchem Biss ja ist der Fisch so fettig
ja ja
klar wenn man hier so reingeht ne du
siehst einfach wie der so zerfli perfekt
GEG wieder mal der zerfließt also wie
können die hier alles so geil machen
also Baby ich habe es mir nicht mal so
gewünscht sondern es kam einfach so und
jetzt weiß ich dass ich mir immer so
wünsche ich hoffe du wunderst dich nicht
dass ich wenn ich dieses shortrip hier
rüber ziehe einfach diesen Löffel in die
Hand nehme ganze Zeit schon so ein ein
Ding im Kopf hä h ist das irgendwie ein
Messer oder der ist aber auch
Rasiermesser Schar dieser Koch ja das
hast du bei tiktok gesehen bestimmt oder
ja richtig ich probiere hier mal so ein
Stück könen ja diger auch diese Soße
dazu ne also das ist einfach das ist es
einfach für mich ne du wirst auch sehen
auch dieses Stückchen schmilzt einfach
in deinem Mund ich habe keine Zweifel
mehr also wirklich ich wäre bedeutend
überraschter wenn etwas nicht gut wäre
als wenn es übertrieben gut wäre weil
ich erwarte hier nichts anderes mehr
dieses US Beef ist von allerhöchster
Güte ganz klar Importartikel kann man in
Deutschland nicht finden normalerweise
und die Zubereitung ist einfach auf
einem Niveau wie ich das selber nicht
hinbringe und ich bin der Meinung ich
kann ein sehr gutes short machen ich
stell gerade wirklich alles in Frage was
ich so glaube zu wissen ich sag dir was
dies fried rice mit Knoblauch Alter
Wahnsinn diese Knoblauch Chips oben
drauf ne junge Alter Bern das ist essen
oder es ist verrückt ist wirklich
verrückt also bevor wir wirklich das
absolute Highlight des Tages glaube ich
probieren es ist nein okay falsch Stopp
das ist das tut allem anderen Unrecht es
ist so ein Ding was ich schon immer
probieren wollte aber dieses WAG yukatsu
Sando alles war ein Highlight alles war
ein Highlight aber bevor wir mein
persönliches Highlight probieren vielen
vielen herzlichen Dank sagen dass du mir
das hier gezeigt hast das ist hammergeil
es war wirklich ein Abend den werde ich
nicht vergessen ich freue mich so
darüber dass du ähnlich euphorisch bist
wie ich hier bestätigt mich natürlich
auch in meiner Meinung und in der
Auswahl des Restaurants das ist
natürlich mit vollen Hosen stinken hier
das ist Frankfurt das ist Mog ja ja muss
man auch ganz klar sagen und kommt ihr
her und haut euch das rein Leute ich
kann es e nur ich kann es euch nur an
Herz legen komm einmal hier in die Mitte
jetzt lass uns diese Peking ess zeig mir
wie man es macht ich möchte als erstes
dass du erstmal dieses Stückchen Haut da
oben drauf ist ich werde es brüderlich
mit Dir teilen oh das ist natürlich auch
ein dickes Ding komm du kriegst sogar
das größere das ist dies brüderliche
Teil von dem and so ist das ist das
wovon wir reden das macht die pcking
Duck aus es geht immer um die Haut es
ist immer die Konsistenz es ist das
leichte der leichte Fettfilm der unter
der Haut ist ja und jetzt kommt das
endenaroma natürlich RA ne gegessen wird
ganz klassisch du hast hier so ein
pannekure ne so dann hast Du hier häusin
so dann mache ich mir immer einmal den
okay hier mache ich auch einmal den so
und dann gehe ich immer her wie so ein
kleinen wrapck genau so perfect amount
von sage ich immer ja zwei Stückchen
Gurke zwei drei Lauch junge diese grose
Haut die kommt hier rein ein Stückchen
drauf ja so sieht aus und dann mache ich
mir immer so da kann man auch abbeißen
von ne aber so Leute verstehe ich nicht
machst einfach so Ding mach den ein
fertig Logo das wird nicht funktionieren
bei mir ja das muss ja viel zu oft
beißen
lass versuchen abzubeißen viel Spaß
damit wie mir nach diesem ganzen vielen
guten Essen ist jedes Mal noch mal aufs
Neue so unfassbar gut schmecken kann du
kannst das jetzt noch mal essen alles ne
ja wir wir haben zum Glück einige
hungrige Mäuler noch hinter der Kamera
Leute es ist es war wirklich also es ist
fast nicht zu begreifen also wirk ganz
ganz ganz ganz ehrlich was das für ein
verrücktes Privileg ist es hat mir einen
riesen Spaß gemacht ich werde auf jeden
Fall zurückkommen schaut bei weren
vorbei wir sehen beim nächsten Video
wieder bis dahin C Ciao vielen vielen
Dank shit
Alter so eine Kleinigkeit zum Ende ja
ach ja